le hockey sur gazon la nouveauté du
village sportif et culturel 2019 à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
des sports des activités culturelles
proposées aux jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
certains ateliers sont animés par des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est le cas de
jérémy aicardi anciens joueurs de
l'équipe de france de rugby à 7
si aujourd'hui j'ai envie de transmettre
parce que tout ce que j'ai appris
pendant ma carrière en tout cas
professionnels mais surtout avancer les
valeurs du rugby le portage les copains
plaisir que le coach tangle ou pas te
félicite quand tu fais des belles
actions avec des créneaux d'une heure
par ateliers les jeunes peuvent
découvrir des sports inhabituel escalade
ventriglisse et sandball ou encore une
activité d'équitation d'une durée d'une
heure trente du sport mais pas seulement
également on pourra retrouver de
l'initiation aux gestes qui sauvent pour
apprendre justement les gestes de
premiers secours et sur la partie
culturelle on va retrouver notamment un
atelier radio avec lfm radio une
exposition du cnoss donc sur une
exposition autour des jeux olympiques
illégalement est intégré l'exposition
trajectoire
une exposition sur la mobilité le
village sportif et culturel c'est du 8
au 19 juillet inscription obligatoire en
2018 près de 800 jeunes ont participé à
cet événement